[Music]
meet poop it's time our smooth
just doing my beauty what he's full of
himself the emoji movie these lights
I'm mountain in here it's such a loaded
no go ahead finish that sentence
[Music]
what Center an emoji okay be cool
welcome to the secret world inside your
phone
we're emojis like me work and live here
each of us does one thing and we have to
nail it every time incoming tax we are
go for men
hoot me
[Music]
what is that I've got to get this phone
fixed this has never happened before
and now alex has made an appointment to
wipe out his phone it's delete you're
not gonna run away from this I made a
mistake but I'm gonna fix it
I think we can make things right
we just have to go to a place where no
emoji has gone before the cloud I know a
shortcut there's maps but no one's ever
left our city I know softer ups
[Music]
what is this place the greatest place
ever I've never eaten another piece of
candy again
high five don't do it don't you do it
it's already been in there once we need
to get the master password access
tonight this might take a while
wait what access tonight we're gonna
have some dance our way out
everybody could dance
[Music]